- When it came to negotiation time,
Bill was real, real stern about a number.
- [Laughing]
- My side, we were stuck at 16,
and his whole deal was
Tom makes 14.
- [Laughing]
- That was really it.
- Yeah, who gonna make more than Tom?
- Yeah.
♪♪♪
- We’re back, baby!
Season 2 of “Untold Stories.”
Appreciate y'all for showing so much love in Season 1.
I’m so excited to be back in the pool hall.
Who we got to start the season off?
- Oh, we got a future first-ballot Hall of Famer.
- What’s up, man?
- Darrelle Revis. How you doin’, man?
- What’s up, Master? How you doin’, man?
- I’m great, man. How you livin’?
- Living well, man.
Taking it one day at a time,
post-career and retirement, so I’m enjoying it.
- They don’t make ‘em like Revis Island no more, man.
There’s a whole lotta people who got “Island” on their social media handles
because of your influence.
- There’s some guys out there.
Jalen Ramsey.
- OK.
- Stephon Gilmore, so,
the saga continues of the shutdown DBs.
-How nice are you on here?
You gonna shut me down right here, what’s up?
Or am I gonna get a couple catches on you?
- Nah, I’mma whoop you on this, dawg.
- [Laughing]
- I’mma whoop you.
- Let’s see what you got.
OK.
- Gimme one.
Got one.
- I guess I’m about to get my ass whooped.
- You start your career in New York with the Jets.
A whole lotta headlines that came out when you was in New York,
during the Rex Ryan era.
- Oh, for sure.
- Rex Ryan, Bart Scott,
there was always something interesting that was gonna come out of that locker room.
- No doubt. We had some characters on the team.
- So talk to me.
Jets-Patriots.
Always a very competitive, fierce game.
Rex Ryan, Bill Belichick.
This one happens to be on “Monday Night Football.”
What's going in leading up to the game?
- We felt we were prepared.
We felt we had a great game plan,
but that was probably one of the worst games I’ve ever played.
We got embarrassed. We lost 45-3.
Tom shredded us. We couldn’t really do much.
We had no momentum that game.
- I cut that game off at halftime, bro, to be honest with you.
I stopped watching at halftime.
- It's a backstory to this.
We had a team meeting the next day, and
the coaching staff is pissed off.
Rex is going through plays, our mistakes.
We were all disgusted about the film.
Its 45-3, you couldn’t—
- [Laughing] What you gonna watch?
- Yeah.
He got so pissed off, he was like, “Everybody, meet me outside right now!”
We’re like, “Meet you on the practice field? Like, OK.”
We meet him out on the practice field.
He’s kinda a little bit ahead of us.
We see him walking to this ditch.
We’re like, “What's up? What's going on?”
- How many guys are outside now at this point?
- It’s coaching staff, team, trainers, might have been. I don’t know, this is—
- Probably the ones digging the ditch.
- A huge group of people.
He stops in front of the ditch, saying his speech.
“We got embarrassed. I know you guys are better than this,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
We can do better as a coaching staff.”
Another assistant coach handed him the ball.
This was the game ball.
He was like, “I’m gonna tell you guys right now,
this will never happen again!”
He’s, like, chanting with the ball and, you know, waving it back and forth.
He’s like, “We’re gonna bury this ball right here, as a coaching staff, as a team.”
Buries the ball,
and then the guy’s over there putting the dirt on it.
- [Laughing] Who’s doing that?
- One of the landscapers obviously that works for the Jets.
We’re just sitting there like,looking like,
“He really just bury the ball?
I’ve never seen this before. Like, this is different.”
- What's going on in your mind?
- It’s very dramatic. It’s psychological as well. But it worked.
- Why did it work?
- We end up playing ‘em in the divisional playoffs.
- What happens?
- We won, 28-21.
And I think that's what fueled us is, you know, Rex’s speech, him burying the ball.
It was the magical ball.
- [Laughing]
- For us to win.
That was the superstition of it.
- [Laughing]
- We were celebrating around all of Gillette Stadium, and
Bart Scott's slogan came out,
the “I can’t wait!”
- Why do you feel like that ball was so magical,
where it motivated the team moving forward?
- I think at that moment, it would’ve made or broke our season.
We could’ve went into a slump.
That was Rex’s touch.
- [Laughing]
- And it worked.
- Where do you think that ball is right now?
- I probably need to call Jets management and see if the ball is still buried there.
It might be, it might be.
- [Laughing]
- It might be.
Have you made any balls yet?
- Oh, yeah, I made one.
Come on, you’re gonna have to give me more credit than that now.
How many years did you spend on the Jets?
- The New York Jets, I was there for eight years.
- You hit free agency.
Who calling your phone from New England?
- At the beginning of it, I was kinda like,
“Ah, I don’t really feel it,” because of the rivalry.
- Does that really matter to athletes like that?
- For me, it did.
For example, I’m gonna use “Space Jam.”
If I played for the Monstars, that's the team I’m representing.
- You switch over to Tune Squad.
- Yeah. So yeah, you switch over to Tune Squad, then,
you know, that’s the squad you playing for.
But when business sets in and the numbers come back,
I decided to team up with the Patriots.
Corner pocket.
- What's Bill Belichick like?
- It’s eggshells. You’re walking on eggshells when you come here.
- [Laughing]
- Bill might come out of the blue, ask you some question.
Like, it goes back to just they want you to know everything about
the preparation or the game day.
I remember one time he asked me a question during a team meeting,
and he was like, “2-4!”
- [Laughing]
- "What is Calvin Johnson's average per catch?”
You’re like, “14.7,” you know.
“How many yards he have so far this year?
How many touchdowns?"
“I don’t know, 10.”
If he could play football, trust me, I mean, he would love to go out there.
His mental and his preparation is so competitive.
I mean, he put on film from 1940.
“I’ve been running this for 40 years!”
We’re sitting there looking at black-and-white TV like,
“Wait, what?”
You gotta give him his respect. That’s why he's a Hall of Famer.
No shot.
- C’mon, bro.
- You caught that.
- I hope you captured that.
- C’mon, man.
- You saw that.